you've become a grandfather again though
recently so congratulations um do
grandkids do they change your
relationships i'm just curious with your
kids cause i see my mom how she acted
with me and then i see how she acts with
my kids and then now we even have a
different relationship does that does
that happen to your family
yeah you know a bit i mean it's a little
different for me because um the kids
were back i guess you know from the kobe
so they were not out of the house yet
and the thing about grandkids is you
always think in terms of well they're
long past when your kids are already
gone for for years you know they're off
for years doing their own plans and now
finally they're going to have children
but this is my oldest son cameron
and his lady vivian this is their
beautiful kids lua who's three and and
ryder who's just three months
so it came on me a little fast
you know i didn't get that long as you
said that out your empty nest transition
before the grandchildren were there yeah
so i'm still working on that
quite honestly a little bit
but i'm looking forward to it they're
they're they're great kids but i do get
a kid a kick and it makes me smile
watching my son and all the stuff that i
went through with him you know and he
was he was a tough honorary tough
honorary guy
uh as a kid and all of that and now
watching his it makes me just smile and
i just savor it in his misery when he's
having a tough day you just do a karma
walk by karma you do the caramel walk by
or then it's always the beauty of the
grandparent you saw that's wonderful
here you go cam thanks very much bye
guys see you i've hyped him up and how's
yours
[Music]
you